voilà c'est mon niveau chez moi ça me
plaît il est temps pour moi de revenir
sur cette année 2016 que ça représente
pour moi vous avez peut-être découvrir
des choses c'est parti l'année commence
très fort avec l'aboutissement de
plusieurs mois de boulot c'est la
diffusion de mon court métrage la
cartouche au grand rex à paris voilà
cette avant-première était très
important pour moi parce que je voulais
avoir la réaction du public en direct et
l'ambiance était vraiment super et puis
les bénéfices ont été reversés à
l'association c'est que du bonheur une
association que j'affectionne tout
particulièrement j'étais super content
de publier enfin on court métrage à
cartouche
c'est le projet qui m'a fait le plus qui
fait 7 jours de tournage un casting au
top une équipe au top un générique d'une
tortue en 3d et une séquence tournée
avec shigeru miyamoto le créateur de
mario il a bien voulu donner ces camps
taiwan ça c'était vraiment un courrier à
bercy miyamoto cela merci nintendo on à
péage et voilà j'ai dû me verse à cette
année un russe et un italien ont repris
mes vidéos mot pour mot dans le plus
grand des cas
cette fois c'est la rançon de la gloire
je leur en veux pas je vais juste les
poursuivre en justice
[Musique]
j'étais jury du nikon film festival
c'est un concours de courts métrages
présidé cette année par l'acteur jacques
gamblin je suis très honoré était
vraiment les clac de visionner des
centaines de courts métrages et c'est là
qu'on se rend compte de la force de
création des français et de tout ce
qu'ils peuvent inventer donc bravo à
tous les participants
bravo à tous ceux qui racontent des
histoires tous les jours on continue
comme ça ne vous arrêtez pas on peut
dire que c'est l'année de la
transformation physique
j'adore changer de gueule alors j'ai pas
hésité j'ai fait le patron de youtube
avec un faux crâne une perruque et une
moustache est l'inventeur des animaux
avec une coupe en brosse et un très beau
book je vous épargne les cheveux dans la
cartouche quand les pubs versus d'avis
devant être youtuber vrai 2016 c'était
l'année de la perruque et cette année je
vais continuer devinez qui est la
personnalité préférée des français
c'est omar sy moi j'ai été élue la
personnalité préférée des 7-14 ans par
le journal d'investigation le journal de
mickey
donc merci beaucoup ça me fait très
plaisir je suis un peu comme votre grand
frère pour vous les jeux alors votre
père bozi mais ses paroles merci
beaucoup et j'ai un feeling
l'année prochaine tu as quiz i just en
2016 pour moi c'est aussi l'année des
rencontres exceptionnelles
arasa en ou séjour au japon je tombe sur
le premier youtuber du monde 51 min
d'abonnés unibail voilà qui a été très
très sympa on a fait une photo j'ai
participé à un tournage un petit peu fou
puisque j'ai tourné avec james mcavoy
professeur xavier pour x-men j'ai adoré
son rôle dans wanted d'un tournage un
petit peu bizarre puisque hui faisait
ses répliques pendant que nous avec
julien jossin lui faisait des grimages
suis pas sûr tous ont en commun
l'expérience pour lui mais en tout cas
nous on a kiffé est ce que c'est la
seule rencontre cette année là pas du
tout la fox m'a contacté pour organiser
une rencontre avec un de mes
réalisateurs préférés
tim burton j'ai vu tellement de fois
tous ces films je faisais même des
dessins je croyais pas et finalement ça
c'est fait j'ai pu discuter avec tim
burton et c'est super enrichissant
l'appareil de création de mise en scène
de dessins de son film miss perry green
et les enfants en particulier c'était
vraiment une super expérience donc merci
beaucoup anti merci la fox vous le savez
maintenant c'est plus un secret j'adore
le manga dragon ball j'en parle dans mes
vidéos et je me suis dit que ça serait
cool de faire une vidéo avec des
passionnés du manga et j'ai fait un quiz
ball voilà sur la chaîne cnn gaming ça
s'est super bien passé c'était une top
ambiance et je fais très honoré d'avoir
la voix officielle de son beaucoup en
france c'est magnifique
merci beaucoup brigitte merci beaucoup à
tous les participants c'était vraiment
les plats comme les deux années
précédentes je suis allé à londres pour
le tournage de you tube rewind cette
année j'y suis allé avec squeeze et
autant les années précédentes mais
passages soient comptés en seconde
autant là ça se compte en dixièmes de
seconde vous en voulez plus c'est parti
voilà c'est tout bon manon vous ne
verrez pas pouces j'espère que ça vous a
plu la légende raconte que l'année
prochaine on verra un centième de
seconde
donc ne clignez plus des yeux merci pour
tous vos dessins après ma vidéo sur ma
passion du dessin j'ai adoré partager ma
passion avec vous parce que c'est un
truc que je fais depuis je suis gamin je
sais qu'elle a peur de tout vous qui ne
dessine pas action foot mais pour moi
c'était cool de vous en parler l'année
2016 c'est aussi une année riche en
collaborations vous m'avez vu sur les
deux chaînes youtube forcément mais
aussi sur la chaîne youtube dans ton
corps chez golden stage chez zucco j'ai
dans le documentaire de petites
histoires dans le studio 404 la chaîne
du cnc chez thomas gautier dans second
life dans la nouvelle édition dont les
cas sont je suis pas si free qui s'est
passé cette année j'ai bossé pendant un
moment sur un projet très secret et
j'étais très très content de pouvoir
enfin vous en parlez vous le montrer et
le lancer j'ai créé un jeu mobile qui
fument
pour mettre un jeu bah oui je vous
présente le nom quiz qui est disponible
sur android et ios gratuitement qu'un
jeu vous allez vous courage et il faut
répondre à des questions mais il ya des
pièges absolument pas recommencer plus
beaucoup de travail développement à
l'écriture en passant par les musiques
les graphismes l'animation donc merci à
toute l'équipe qui a bossé là dessus que
c'est vraiment un rêve pour moi de créer
un jeu il ya une personne qui a été très
important dans ce projet vous expliquer
ça je vais revenir 15 ans en arrière et
nous présent dans le va et je passais
tout mon temps libre à créer des trucs
avec mon pote jeremic et ici sur cette
photo du 18 mai 2002 c'était mon
anniversaire je me suis là et lui il est
l'or vous n'êtes pas trop près ils
abondent de sa gueule on passer tout
notre temps libre à créer des trucs on a
créé des petits jeux vidéo moi je
m'occupais des dessins essentiellement
on a grandi ensemble on est montée sur
paris lui il s'est spécialisé dans le
développement sur mobile
moi j'ai fait des vidéos ça vous êtes au
courant et on s'est dit et si on faisait
ce qu'on faisait à 15 ans c'est à dire
oui et des jeux mais notre la journée
cette fois ci et c'est ce qu'on a fait
jérémy a quitté son talent maintenant on
crée des petits jeux ensemble et même si
une prix c'est un petit jeu c'est la
continuité de ce qu'on faisait quand on
était gamins avec les mêmes personnes la
même passion et on va avoir encore plein
d'autres projets on va mettre à jour le
quiz va voir plein d'autres contenus
dans pas très longtemps et on va aussi
faire un autre jeux des jeux plus long
qui seront payants voilà désormais bien
que jeremy ben merci à tous ceux qui ont
déjà téléchargé le jeu ça a été en top
d'app store et de google play pendant
très longtemps on a peur des fêtes donc
que ça fait très plaisir c'était pas
loin pour l'action et vous le savez très
probablement mais ma chaîne youtube a
dépassé les 10 millions d'abonnés je
vous remercie chaleureusement je ne
m'étale pas pourquoi je ne m'étale pas
parce que une vidéo spéciale que j'ai
tourné pendant le mois de décembre à
arriver dans pas très longtemps c'est ma
prochaine vidéo en indice sur la vidéo
je peux vous dire que je n'étais pas
chez moi que j'ai vécu ça pendant plus
de dix jours et peut-être il ya un
trophée en diamant à la clé c'est
possible je n'en dis pas plus arrive
très bientôt j'ai oublié plein de choses
pour cette année 2016 va tourner et
dédicaces pour la bd la paris games week
le sens du jeu laisse tout ça mais en
tout cas merci
cette année de folie c'est un truc de
fou et pour 2017 j'ai plein de projets
jeu bd courts métrages séries vous est
peut-être déjà entendu parler donc
rester dans le coin bonne année et
faites comme moi c'est partout toute
façon des membres ont approuvé la
katusha ligue poitou on a cherché
partout tout récent des cantonales
abonnez vous